bonjour Gulliver Craig on vous retrouve
en direct devant cet immeuble le dernier
bilan fait état de trois morts
oui je pense que vous voyez derrière moi
l'immeuble est complètement détruit de
l'avenir jusqu'à la tour derrière et on
est sur l'avenue principale des aporisa
en plein centre-ville pour le moment le
bilan officiel est de 3 morts mais parmi
les sauveteurs ici quelqu'un m'a dit
qu'il pensait qui aurait été c'était
5000 n'étaient pas sur encore mais ce
qui est assez évident c'est que dans les
décombres derrière moi il peut y avoir
encore des personnes il est très
difficile vu l'état de ces décombres et
le fait que le feu n'est toujours pas
éteint de les extraire et il y a un
homme ici au moins qui dit que il y a
des membres de sa famille qui sont
disparus qu'ils cherchent d'autres
voisins du quartier regardent avec une
très grande inquiétude et c'est toute
une ville qui est sous le choc en
réalité parce que même si ça pourrait
déjà a été frappé maintes fois depuis le
début de cette invasion le 24 février en
fait c'était l'une des premières villes
à être frappé au petit matin du 24
février jamais les missiles n'étaient
tombés aussi du centre-ville et aussi on
est vraiment dans un quartier commercial
et résidentiel il n'y a aucun objet
militaire ou industriel ici
merci pour ces éléments Gulliver crack
en direct de vaporida pour France 24